hello everyone I know that each and
every one of you probably have that too
one game that you consider to be the
most beautiful chess game but this is
the game actually that brought me the
most joy the first time I saw it and it
was about the time that I first started
reading chess books I had a book about
old masters and after I saw this game I
repeated it like a hundred times over
the chess board I showed it to all my
friends well those who played chess
there weren't really a lot of them but I
was really amazed at this game and by a
defenders and himself and by his style
of play and this game was played in 1852
it's played between Adolphe Anderson and
one of his students Jean the phrase if
that is how it's pronounced I'm not
really sure so let's see this game the
game holds the title the Evergreen game
or the Evergreen game as well it never
gets old
it'll probably it'll probably be
exciting to look at this game even 500
years from now so let's see this game
Anderson is white and the run is black
we have E 4 E 5 and yeah I forgot it's
after this game and after a while let's
just get to the move Knight f3 with
Knight to c6 Bishop to c4 so detail in
game Bishop to c5 and here we have B for
the Evans gambit it's uh definitely my
favorite opening with the white pieces
if I if I am ever able to play before I
will play before it doesn't really have
to be the Evans gambit I will play
before against the Sicilian I do enjoy
an occasional wing gambit and well I
really enjoyed the idea of b4 as a move
so we have Bishop character some before
we have c3 so basically white gives up a
couple of points for extremely rapid
development we have Bishop a5 and now d4
we have it captures on d4 so giving up
another pawn and castles and here since
Jean is out of student he knows that D
captures on c3 can get a bit too
dangerous for black so instead he plays
d3 okay well we have Queen to b3 now
attacking this f7 square and
well black does have to defend this and
also he has to figure out a way how to
castle so he plays Queen to f6 preparing
Knight to e7 and maybe Dan castling we
have b5 not allowing black any time to
breed we have Queen to g6 and here we
have rook to e1 and okay now like not
what I can play here we have night night
g37 we have a bishop to a3 and now it's
not really pinning tonight or anything
but but it's useful useful square for
the bishop as this diagonal is very
strong and here black has a number of
options you can play d6 you can push d5
maybe just castling it would be best
even even if it's not the best move but
it would be best for a human to play it
but instead as those those were the
moves in old times he played b5 black
wants to give up some material to get
some development himself so anderson
place queen capture some b5 would have
worked the g8 we have Queen to a4 and
now again probably best thing for black
would be the castle here but he plays a
Bishop to b6 now he's also kind of
eyeing this f2 pawn
we have Knight B to d2 and here Bishop
to b7 again probably casting here would
have been best but black for a price of
one pawn black now has this both bishops
are attacking f2 and g2 at some point
and he he does have a broken open file
after the bishop smooth Anderson plays
Knight to e4 we have Quinta if between
to f5 and again instead of Queen to a5
probably there were better moves
probably castling was better here and
here Anderson plays Bishop captures on
d3 and now Anderson is well threatening
all sorts of discoveries after this
Knight moves and this Queen doesn't
really have a lot of squares to go to so
he tries a Queen to h5 and here Anderson
starts his maneuvering he plays Knight
to f6 which is forking the king and the
Queen so the knight has to be captured
from plays G captures on f6 we have he
captures on f6 and well this wasn't
really a sacrifice as white will win the
piece
back and well since black doesn't really
see any threats here he plays rook the
g8 and this rook the g8 move is actually
the best move and well this is the this
is the most critical position probably
one of the most critical positions of
all chess positions as well black is
black is threatening Queen captures on
f3 as the pawn won't be able to
recapture but if he plays this White has
a crushing attack and it's very high
very hard to find the defensive move for
black in this position I will let you
try and find a defensive move for black
on your own so you can try some of your
ideas in the comment section here
Anderson played a spectacular move he
played rook a to d1 it's a slow silent
move but the consequences of this move
will be deadly so John of course didn't
really understand this move and he
played Queen captures on f3 which is you
know it's a good move he rubs a piece
and he's threatening Queen captures and
g2 with checkmate it sound very easy to
stop this if white tries g3 or something
then this Knight can move with a temple
and then this Bishop and queen are also
ready to deliver checkmate on g2 but
here Anderson has a crushing crushing
combination he plays rook captures on e7
would check and well what's black gonna
do here if if he tries something like
King King f8 is of course impossible he
steps right in the bishops path then
simply rook to a3 wins the Queen or
maybe maybe white can even made here and
if well best move for black would be
something like King to d8 but what would
White would still prevail here but what
John played allowed the under Center to
finish the game in great style and this
is why the game got its name he captured
the rock he played Knight captures on e7
and here we have Anderson's
great idea that's the that is the whole
point of rook a to d1
he plays the Queen captures on d7 with
check and well the black doesn't really
have any options he plays something like
King to f8 and simply Bishop or Queen
captures a nice
and this is checkmate a very nice
checkmate so after Queen to d7 black
decided to play King captures on d6 d7
as well
we saw how King f8 loses and here we
have a pure Anderson move as this is
something this is a this is a theme
you'll see in a lot of Anderson's games
he plays Bishop to f8 the Bishop to a5
would check and this is actually a
double check as there's a discovery from
drop and b1 now and well only squares
available for a black King or c6 and e8
and if black King will go to c6 then
it's mating 1 it's actually Bishop to d7
checkmate as this LightSquared Bishop is
while slicing this way this dark square
Bishop is slicing all the way here and
rope is covering d5 so a beautiful a
beautiful checkmate so after this Bishop
to f5 double check he played King to e8
but this allows I check made that that's
just as great he plays Anderson plays
Bishop to d7 good check we have King to
f8 or King - it doesn't really Kim to DA
doesn't really matter
and here Anderson finishes the game put
Bishop captures on e7 with checkmate as
well g7 square is covered from the pawn
and this is this is a beautiful mating
picture and it's it's it's an extremely
beautiful game it's definitely an
evergreen game as the title would
suggest and look at these bishops here
it's the greatest bishop pair ever
they're they're quite a team so yeah I
do hope you enjoyed this game like I
said this is the game I consider to be
the most beautiful as it brought me
great joy and and it still does and I
would like to thank Mickey gramatical
thank you for contribution to my channel
I really appreciate it this is actually
our second time contributing so I'm glad
you're still enjoying my content thank
you a lot sir and yeah as usual you can
check two of my previous videos here
thank you all for watching and I will
see you soon